KATIE: Today I'm pleased
to welcome
John Butman here today.
As you know, he is the author of
"Breaking Out." How to bu--
I'm sorry.
The full title is "Breaking Out,
How to Build Influence in
a World of Competing Ideas."
He's also the founder and
principal of Idea Platforms,
which happens to be just down
the street here in Kendall.
So he works at Idea Platforms
and he works with other
content experts on [INAUDIBLE],
helping them
develop and go public with their
ideas in a variety of
different expressions and forms,
from social media, to
apps, to print, to print
books, and videos.
He's worked with leaders,
and universities, and
philanthropies, consultancies,
and businesses, as well as
independent professionals.
His work is actually taking
him to 30 different
countries--
I wish mine would do that.
[INAUDIBLE]
And their ideas have been
featured in dozens of
publications.
They have been featured in
speaking venues worldwide,
including the World Economic
Forum at Davos,
PopTech, and TEDx.
He's also been included in
The Thinkers50 list.
Their books have appeared on
"The New York Times," "Boston
Globe," "Businessweek," and
"Toronto Globe and Mail"
bestseller list.
"Breaking Out" in particular
has been featured in "The
Financial Times," "Forbes,"
inc.com, "Huffington Post,"
"Harvard Business Review,"
"Bloomberg" and plenty more
that I'll leave off.
But personally, I
read the book.
I really enjoyed reading it.
In fact, I shared the book with
my brother who was at
Google here, too, and also
an author, and he
really enjoyed it.
And hopefully he's going to
share it with others, because
that's a part of how
ideas are spread.
But I don't want to give too
much or anything away because
this is why we brought
John here today.
So I'll hand it over to John.
JOHN BUTMAN: Great, thank
you very much, Katie.
Thanks you.
Thanks to everybody
for coming.
Happy pre-lunch to you.
I am indeed the principal
of Idea Platforms.
Anna Weiss is my colleague
and associate.
She was very involved in the
writing and creation of the
book, too, so I want
to acknowledge her.
And the title of my
talk today is--
if we can make this go-- how do
people gain influence for
an abstract idea?
So it's a very simple question
I'm addressing.
And the question is, if you have
an idea for how you would
like to make a difference in
the world, how you want to
make some kind of change
in the world--
there is the world out there,
there are people whose minds
you want to influence, whose
thinking you want to
influence, and whose behavior
you want to change.
And in between is this thing
that I call the ideaplex,
which is all the stuff, all the
channels, and all the ways
you can get to people.
So how do you go from the idea
in your head to the idea in
other people's heads?
Very difficult to do.
That's what I've been studying,
that's what we'll be
talking about today.
So two important things
about this.
I'm talking about people,
not about companies.
So it's about how do individuals
do this?
And I'm talking about
abstract ideas.
So I'm not talking about ideas
for companies or for products.
So when I say abstract idea,
let me just give you a few
examples so you know what
I'm talking about.
So for example, abstract idea.
You know civil disobedience.
Abstract idea.
I can never spell while
I'm doing this.
I like to both do the pen thing
and the click thing.
I feel that you need two
ways to apprehend.
Leaning in.
This is probably familiar
to you.
Everyone know--
recognize that one, right?
Creative destruction.
Alright, I told Anna this one
yesterday and she said, I
never heard of it before.
Continuous improvements.
Interestingly enough, I mean,
here's one that's been around
and it's become so embedded we
don't even think of it as an
idea anymore.
But when it first started,
some 50 years ago,
this was a big idea.
It was an abstract idea that
people didn't really get.
They thought you just
kept on going.
Anybody want to volunteer
abstract idea?
Well, that.
Oh, yeah.
Quantified self.
It's--
I like this one.
Quantified self is kind
of a new one.
So, this is the kind of thing
I'm talking about.
How do these ideas
get out there?
So my goal with this
talk is twofold.
First of all, I would
like to help you.
If you want to go public
with an idea.
If you have an idea that you
would like to plant in some
minds, whether it's just within
your community, or
within your discipline, or
within your unit, or
the world at large.
And second, there are so many
ideas out there coming at us
that I would like to give you
some thoughts about how to
evaluate these ideas that are
constantly flooding around us.
So, let me first just talk a
little bit about the ideaplex,
because this is one of the
reasons that we have
this glut of ideas.
So by the ideaplex I mean all
the activities by which we
generate, distribute,
and consume ideas.
And what's interesting is the
countries that Anna and I
visited as part of the research
for the book, the
ideaplex in the US is really
different, and much bigger,
and much more complex
than anywhere else.
So the idea entrepreneur I'm
going to talk about in just a
moment is really a product
of the ideaplex.
And I'm talking about from the
entire educational system to
social media, traditional media
in between, think tanks,
research and development--
I mean, there are so
many places that
ideas are coming from.
So the ideaplex makes it easier
to go public because
you can just post a YouTube
video, you could just tweet,
and you're public.
But it makes it harder to gain
influence because everybody's
tweeting, and everybody's
going public.
So it's interesting that
it's easier and
harder at the same time.
But it has given rise to this
new player that I call the
idea entrepreneur.
So this is an individual.
These are some of the
characteristics.
It's an idea driven person.
They tend to be outsiders to
a status quo of some kind.
They can be within an
organization but still be
outside the status
quo thinking.
They tend to model the
ideas themselves.
The ideas are always
life-affirming in some way.
They are very personally
motivated.
And they always seek some
kind of change.
So they're looking to make
some kind of change in
something--
can be a mindset, can be an
organization, it can be quite
small, it can be quite large.
So, who am I talking about?
Let me just give you
a few examples.
Sheryl Sandberg.
So, she wrote the book
"Lean In." What's
she trying to change?
She's trying to change attitudes
about women in the
workplace and in society.
Daniel Kahneman.
Anybody read his book,
"Thinking, Fast and Slow"?
So he's a behavioral
psychologist.
He's trying to change
how people go
about making decisions.
And he gets into business
decision making.
Mireille Giuliano.
Anybody read her book?
"French Women Don't Get Fat." So
she's trying to change how
people think about eating
and lifestyle.
And her basic thing is, you
should do it the way the
French do it.
Atul Gawande.
Everyone know him?
So he's trying to change how
surgeons think about the ways
they behave in the
operating room.
He wrote "The Checklist
Manifesto."
Very interesting fellow.
Anna's seen him speak.
Tim Ferriss.
Anybody a Tim Ferriss
adherent?
Is anybody--
you are?
AUDIENCE: My email is.
JOHN BUTMAN: For the work week,
the body, or the, what
are all three?
The work week, OK.
So Tim Ferriss is trying to
change how you think about,
sort of, everything, right?
But he's saying you should do
everything faster and you
should optimize yourself.
And he's a self quantification
guy.
You probably haven't heard of
this guy, Bindeshwar Pathak.
We met him in India,
fascinating guy.
He is trying to change how
Indians think about
sanitation.
He believes that sanitation is
the way for success for the
nation of India.
These are-- actually, this
is a group of these, the
untouchables, right?
Former scavengers who we had
a chance to meet in India.
Eckhart Tolle.
Anybody read Eckhart Tolle?
"The Power of Now." Hugely
successful author and speaker.
He's trying to change how people
think about being in
the moment and about
spirituality.
Bryant Terry.
He's a chef and he's
into nutrition.
He's trying to change how you
think about social justice.
He says nutrition is the
way to social justice.
Now I just want to--
those people are all quite
famous and quite well-known.
So I want to show you a
couple who are not.
This is Maria Madison, who
actually lives in my town of
Concord, Mass.
And she's trying to
change how people
think about their community.
So she's doing it in
a very small way.
She runs this little
group called The
Drinking Gourd Project.
And this is a young woman named
Samantha Joseph who is a
friend of Anna's.
She works for Iron Mountain and
she's trying to change how
people within the company think
about sustainability.
So, all the ideas I'm going to
present to you, although we
basically focused on well-known
people who have
bestselling books, these apply
within communities.
The ideas apply within
communities and within
organizations.
So, finally, Cesar Millan,
the dog whisperer.
Does everybody know
the dog whisperer?
You've seen him,
seen his shows.
So, they are all very different,
obviously, but they
all follow a basic method.
It's not really a set of steps,
but there are three
parts to this method.
Fascination, expression,
and respiration.
I'm going to very
briefly take you
through those three things.
So, the first one.
Fascination.
If we look at Cesar Millan,
he's got a great story.
He was born in Mexico, he was
raised on a farm, spent time
on a farm as a kid.
Everybody discovered that he
was really good with dogs.
He seemed to be able to
communicate with dogs unlike
anybody else.
And when he was in his early
teens, his family got a TV set
for the first time.
And he came across
American shows.
And, believe it or not, his
favorite show was "Rin Tin
Tin."
And then he came across
"Lassie." And he said, wow,
this is really very different.
The way these dogs behave is not
the way the dog's behave
on the farm here in Mexico.
I must go to America and
discover what the training
techniques are for these dogs
because these dogs understand
English, they respond to
commands, they seem to have
relationships, they live in
houses, they wear clothing.
I don't get what's going on.
So this was a moment of
revelation for him.
Now, so, his fascination with
dogs has remained a part of
his presentation for
his entire life, so
for the last 30 years.
And this particular story he
tells over and over again.
I went to see him do a live--
he does this live talk, this
hour-long kind of stage show.
I went to Lynn, Massachusetts
and saw him do this.
And he told this story about
seeing "Rin Tin Tin." He tells
it every time he talks--
virtually.
And every time he talks about
it, he says it as if it
happened yesterday.
So these are-- so fascination is
about these iconic moments.
And all of these idea
entrepreneurs have these
iconic moments that
reveal the idea.
So they are able to tell you,
here's when I came to
understand this idea.
Mireille Giuliano, for example--
"French Women Don't
Get Fat." She talks about how
she came to America when she
was a kid and she was a
perfectly slim, fit, young
Frenchwoman.
She came here.
She lived in five
different homes.
When she was a high school
student, everybody plied her
with lemon meringue pie, and
brownies, and frappes, and
stuff like that.
And she gained 20 pounds.
And it really did not
make her happy.
She went home, her father said
to her, oh my god, you look
like a sack of potatoes.
So that moment is one that she
talks about all the time.
So these iconic moments are
very much a part of
fascination.
Then there is--
all these idea entrepreneurs
have huge quantity of
accumulation.
So they accumulate lots, and
lots, and lots of material.
And we find this--
as Katie said, we work with
people who come to us, who are
content experts, who want to go
public, and often they want
to write a book.
And they say to us, do we
have enough material?
And very often they do not
have enough material.
And you really need a great deal
of material behind your
idea to convince people
in lots and lots
of different ways.
So you need data, you need
stories, you need references,
you need analysis, you
need all this stuff.
And a friend of mine, George
Stalk, who's a strategy expert
said, well, he has a test for
how much material you need
because he's always asked how
much do you need before you
write a book?
He said, well, if you can
stand up in front of an
audience for a full day and
talk nonstop, and have the
audience stay reasonably awake,
you probably have
enough for a book.
So you can use that test if
you want to write a book.
They also, they always
have practices.
So all these idea entrepreneurs
are very
practical people.
This is what really
distinguishes them from the
abstract thinkers, the
academics, those who are
interested in writing books but
don't make it practical.
So what we found is that they
really have to find a way to
allow people, making people
understand how do you put this
idea into everyday use?
So obviously, Cesar Millan
gives you ways to
deal with your dog.
But Daniel Kahneman gives you
a series of questions to ask
if we make a decision.
All of these guys, all these
people, give you practices.
It's very, very important.
So, they take all this stuff
and they build a personal
narrative around their idea.
And what's really great is the
personal narrative is the
story of the idea.
It's a story of how the
idea developed.
It's the abstraction of the
idea, but it's the life story.
So the person essentially
becomes the idea.
This is very difficult to do.
All the people I showed you
pretty much to that.
But you can do it in
a smaller way.
So you can say that person is
the one who knows more than
anybody else in the organization
about whatever it
is, and that is the person who
is really espousing this idea
and has put themselves
into it.
So their personal narrative is
really entwined with the idea.
So the second part of the
method is expression.
Now obviously, the fas-- these
three overlap and they're
simultaneous.
But the expression comes next.
So by expression I simply mean
that your idea is pretty much
nothing until you have expressed
it in some way.
And I've done many talks and
people come up to me
afterwards and say, I have this
really fantastic idea but
nobody is doing it.
And I'll say, well, have
you told anybody
about it, for example?
Well, say, yeah.
Well, I told somebody
about it.
But the idea entrepreneurs
express their ideas in
multiple ways, all the time.
So the first thing to do is to
figure out what is their best
form of expression.
And this is not so easy to do,
because if you don't spend
your life in communications
you may not know what your
best form is.
So we found people come to us
who want to write books are
not actually writers, and it's
very difficult to write.
And so we help them try to
find what their best
expression is.
So, very often, people are much
better talkers than they
are writers, and that's
where idea
entrepreneurs should start.
So, Cesar Millan, for example,
is a great talker.
He's great in person,
but as a writer--
I mean, he's fine.
His books are fine, but you
really want to see the guy.
Mireille Giuliano is actually
a very good writer.
You want to read her books.
They are fun to read.
They're interesting to read.
And she likes to talk, but it's
kind of secondary to her.
So this writing speaking tension
is very intriguing
because you really
need to do both.
And they do very different
things.
We found that all idea
entrepreneurs do
both of these things.
But whatever the best form is,
and even if they do both, they
always create what we call
a sacred expression.
So this is the one expression
that everybody comes to
recognize and say,
that is the one.
That is the book this
person wrote.
That's the one you
should read.
And if you don't have that,
it's very hard to go up a
level when you go public.
So people who really want to
take it up a level, and go
public, and get a lot of
attention, they really have to
put a lot of work into
the expression.
And it's not enough just to
write a book, just to do a
video, just to do a talk.
You have to put a lot into it.
But all the accumulation, all
the iconic moments, all the
practices--
they all have to be there in
the sacred expression.
Then you have to put a lot of
work into making it both
quality, but also get out
there so people see it.
Finally, they do, as I said,
multiple expressions.
And what they really want to do
is create a video, a talk,
tweet, blog, write, write
articles, appear in
conferences, appear at TED Talks
if they possibly can.
But every piece of--
each expression does something
a little bit different.
So when I first saw Malcolm
Gladwell speak, it was really
interesting.
He did his talk about "The
Tipping Point." And I don't
know if you've seen him talk
about that, and I'm not sure
if it changes or not.
But when I saw him, it was
just after it came out.
And he got up and he told the
first story from the book.
And basically, in the
same words that he'd
written it in the book.
And I thought, well, I've
already read the book.
I don't need you to read
the book aloud,
there's audio to do that.
So I'd rather have you tell me
other stuff and explain to me
things in the book, or tell
me other stories.
So the great idea entrepreneurs
make their talk
different from the book.
I found this very difficult when
we started off with this
book because you've spent three,
four years working on
all the stuff in your book
and then suddenly nobody
wants to hear that.
They want to hear new stuff.
So well, I don't have any
new stuff right now.
But you have to come
up with new stuff.
So the talk has to be different
from the book.
The video has to be different
from the talk and the book.
So all these multiple
expressions start to build
this self-reinforcing platform
that's really fantastic.
And we've seen this with our
books-- it's been really,
really fun to watch.
Because we've been blogging
on the "HBR" blog
network, which has--
I think it goes out to
a million people.
So I don't know if
anybody looks at
that, the blog network.
But they have five or
six blogs per day.
And they're always running their
analytics on them so you
can see where you fall
in the ranking.
It is very dangerous for an
author to do this because you
can waste your entire day
checking your analytics of
your Amazon ranking
and where you
fall in the blog hierarchy.
But you want to build this
self-reinforcing platform.
And that's what all the
idea entrepreneurs do.
Then we come to the third piece,
which is really the
most important and fun one.
Am I going to write on the
wall if I do this?
I was told not to write
on the wall.
I would be kicked
out immediately.
KATIE: The building's too
new for you to write on
the wall just yet.
JOHN BUTMAN: All right.
So I'll squeeze it in down
here while you do that.
So respiration.
This is the most
important one.
This is where influence really
starts to happen.
So you can have a fascination.
You can accumulate a
ton of material.
You can create a lot
of expressions.
And you can have absolutely
no influence at all.
And it happens all the time.
And this happened to a couple of
our clients and it's a very
unpleasant experience.
You put all this work into it.
Usually we find that putting all
the work into it will pay
off eventually, but it
may not pay off with
this particular effort.
So what is respiration?
This is when the idea comes
to life, when the
idea starts to breathe.
When people pick it up, when
they tell each other about it,
and they start to put
into practice.
All these things happen.
So this is what we really want
to have happen to your idea to
make some kind of change.
Now, you cannot force this
to happen, but you
can encourage it.
So there are a lot of
things you can do.
So the first one, first thing
you can do is you have some
kind of direct engagement.
The number of authors we've
worked with who feel that once
the book is done, or once the
video is done, or once the
talk is done--
it's done.
I have presented my idea
unto the world.
The world will now completely
understand it.
They will take it on board.
They will act accordingly.
My work is finished.
I can ride off into
the sunset.
Right?
So this never happens.
Never ever happens.
Even if they do go
give a talk--
just like I'm giving now--
they don't actually ask for
questions, or don't listen to
what people say.
And so there's no direct
engagement.
All the successful idea
entrepreneurs have some kind
of direct engagement.
Eckhart Tolle, is, I
think he's sort of
my model for this.
He has so many ways of engaging
directly with audiences.
He tried to do sort
of big tent shows,
where he would go into--
I don't think he went to Madison
Square Garden-- but he
want to very big venues and he
didn't like it, because he's
kind of a shy guy.
What he likes to do is be in a
video studio with an audience
about the size of this group.
And people would get up and ask
him really deep, probing,
personal questions.
Like, I'm about to commit
suicide, what do you
think I should do?
Oh my god.
And he will say, oh, well.
And you can see him
kind of stumbling.
And he's not polished.
He's really trying to
help this person.
He's directly engaging.
And when he does it, something
magical happens in the
audience because you see this
guy's putting his ideas to
work, right here, with somebody
who has a real problem.
And you see the person is
helped in some way.
Cesar Millan does the
same thing on stage.
He brings on dogs who he's not
met before who have problems.
Presenting problems.
Right.
So when I saw him, the
dog was a barker.
Yeah, he barked at every
dog that went by.
And Cesar, really, within three
minutes this dog was
totally changed.
It was just by his presence,
by the way he
behaved with the dog.
But Cesar had the new dog.
The dog had come out, and
he walked his own dog
named Junior by.
And the guest dog had barked
like crazy at Junior and tried
to pull at his leash.
And at the end of it, after
three minutes, Cesar walked by
with Junior and the dog just,
sat there like, no problem,
there's another dog here.
So direct engagement is
absolutely essential.
The second one is--
we're still in respiration--
our current presence.
Now, I don't know if you've
witnessed this, but very often
if you hear an author or
somebody with a set of ideas
interviewed on the radio or on
TV, they will often say those
killing words, "as I said in my
book." " No one cares what
you said in your book.
They want to know what you
think about what's
happening right now.
So every idea entrepreneur has
to find a way to develop a
framework of ideas that is
stable, that they believe in,
and they don't change all the
time, but they can interpret
and apply to what's going
on right now.
So all the good ones will be
able to take their ideas and
apply them to whatever
is happening.
And then people have--
they get the, what I call,
this current presence.
So Deepak Chopra.
You know Deepak Chopra?
He's quite brilliant at this.
He's so brilliant
at it that he's
kind of lost the framework.
He's so much a personality of
the ideaplex and he's so able
to respond to everything.
Remember he was all over
the place when
Michael Jackson died?
So he was somehow--
Deepak Chopra was the expert
on Michael Jackson.
I'm not quite sure why, but it's
sort of like, if you need
somebody to talk about anything,
call Deepak.
He will apply his ideas, he'll
fix them somehow so they fit.
So, from my point, he's kind of
lost the idea thing, he's
become a personality
of the ideaplex.
Contrast him to Jim Collins, for
example, who has done four
books, basically, four major
books in a pretty--
Deepak Chopra, by the way, has
done 65 books in his 30 years.
So there's quite a
difference there.
But he very, very much sticks
with his ideas.
He evolves them over time.
He looked at--
he said, well, how do my ideas
apply to social sectors and
did this whole monograph.
So there's a way to have a
current presence which doesn't
threaten your ideas, but it
also keeps you current.
Very important--
OK, I'm continuing respiration
here-- is they personally
model the practices.
So once they go public and
they've talked about these
practices, but they model
them as things continue.
So two examples.
Martha Stewart, who I think of
as an idea entrepreneur.
She kind of got a little bit
focused on the money for quite
some time, but she started out
as an idea entrepreneur.
And the great thing
about her is she
has practices, obviously.
I mean, she's got more practices
than you could shake
a stick at.
She's got nothing but
practices, really.
And what happened when
she went to prison?
Does anybody know?
I mean, the reports vary.
It's a little hard to
get the exact story.
But, as far as we can
tell, she taught
people how to do yoga.
She cooked.
She did knitting
or crocheting.
And she advocated for better
food in prisons from prison.
So she didn't become angry, she
didn't shut down, she kept
doing her practices.
I thought, this is
pretty good.
And, to me, OK, she had her
problems with the whole
financial thing--
I don't know what happened
there, really--
but she kept going with
her practices.
Contrast that with Al Gore.
Remember Al Gore and
his whole thing
with the carbon footprint?
So he came out with "An
Inconvenient Truth." He's the
only guy who has a PowerPoint
presentation that led to a
Nobel Peace Prize and
an Academy Award.
That's not bad.
I think that's, you know--
well, anyway.
But while he was out there,
going public with his ideas,
he got a lot of backlash because
of his enormous house,
his enormous jet-- he was flying
around all the time.
His carbon footprint
was just way off.
So he was not modeling
the practices.
Now, as far as I can tell,
Al has changed his ways--
got a smaller house, and he's
reduced his carbon footprint.
So he heard that message.
But you've got to model
the practices.
That's very, very important.
Two other things
in respiration.
One is, you're always going to
have backlash if you have an
idea of any intensity.
You're going to have to expect
you're going to get backlash
of some kind.
So, you hope you get very
intense positive reactions,
but you're probably
going to get very
intense negative reactions.
So, my favorite example
of this is Amy Chua.
Remember her?
She wrote a book called
The Tiger--
"Battle Hymn of the Tiger
Mother." Yeah.
So this -- what?
Two or three years ago?
Oh my god.
Do you remember there was huge,
huge hyperventilation.
It wasn't respiration, it was
beyond respiration to
hyperventilation in
the ideaplex.
Everybody went nuts.
There was an excerpt from "The
Wall Street Journal" from her
book, and I forget how
many comments.
I think it had 9,000 comments.
It got more comments than any
other article had ever
received for "The Wall Street
Journal," before or since.
So, she was really not
prepared for this.
I mean, she went out thinking,
I am presenting what I think
are some good ideas
about parenting.
And, wow.
She did not expect
this to happen.
And part of it was, she ran into
some pretty heavy trends
in the Zeitgeist.
You know, that was a time when
we were all worried about
China, and said, oh my god,
China is going to completely
eat our lunch.
And every parent was worried
about their kids, saying, oh
my god, none of our kids are
going to get into college.
And so Amy Chua was saying,
you know, really, all the
parenting techniques here in
America, they're fine and
everything, but we could use a
little more of the hard and
metric-driven parenting.
So parents went insane.
So you have to expect
this backlash.
And you have to find a way to
not try to rebut it, but
encompass it.
So Cesar Millan, for example,
he's taken a
great deal of backlash.
He does not have a degree
in veterinary science.
He didn't go to--
he does not have a college
degree at all.
And so the establishment
doesn't like him.
And they say he's set back
dog training 20 years.
And he just deals with that.
He says, this is, you know,
people feel this way.
This is how I operate.
It's just part of the thing.
And the final part of
respiration is meta story.
And this is one-- this is really
part of the ideaplex.
This is the part I find
really fascinating.
People have come to be as
interested in the story of
getting your story out there as
they are in the idea that
you're actually getting out.
So for a while they say, oh,
that's really interesting.
And with our book, for example,
for a month or so,
they said, you know, I've read
the book, interesting ideas,
really interesting.
But after about two months, it
was like, so how's it going?
How many books have you sold?
Oh, you were on, whatever,
Big Think.
So people really want to know
the story of getting
the story out there.
And so idea entrepreneurs have
started to always include meta
story in story.
And that, to me, is really
fascinating.
So people, they want the idea,
but they also want
to know how it went.
And they want this validation
of the fact that you're
actually having success out
there in the ideaplex.
So those two things
go together.
So that's the method.
Now, just a couple thoughts
about some other issues,
because this one is
really critical to
getting an idea out there.
Now, you'd sort of think that
you would know who your key
audience is, but it's surprising
how often people do
not know who they're
talking to.
And they're kind of talking
to themselves.
So they think I have a really,
really great idea.
I really love talking to
myself about this idea.
I'm sure that other people
really will love it, too.
So I think I'll write a book,
or I'll go public.
And they find that it's really
not always the case.
But, more often, there
is an audience you
think you want to influence.
So Atul Gawande, "The Checklist"
doctor, he really
wanted to influence surgeons
and medical staff.
And clearly that's
his audience.
But he had to go to an adjacent
audience to really
get to them.
So you have your direct
audience, but you may not be
able to talk to them directly.
You may have to go to an
adjacent audience.
So this is very intriguing.
Now, Atul Gawande got picked up
by the business community,
I think more so than
it got picked up
by the medical community.
And then it sort of went back
to the direct audience.
They said, oh, well I guess we
better pay attention to this.
So, often you want to go to an
adjacent audience to get back
to your direct audience.
So you got to think about what
are the adjacent audiences?
You often don't know.
So Mireille Giuliano, the
"French Women Don't Get Fat"
lady, she said, well, my direct
audience is probably
sort of middle-aged women,
well-educated, who have
weight, they're struggling
with their weight or with
their health and lifestyle.
So I want to talk to
them directly.
And they did read the book.
But she found she got more
response from young mothers
who were worried
about the kids.
So she had this whole young
mother audience.
Then she discovered that
grandmothers were reading the
book because they said, oh, this
reminds me of how things
were back in my day when we
climbed the stairs all the
time, didn't watch TV, and
only ate whatever.
So she kind of surrounded
her direct audience.
And then she discovered
that the spouses
were reading the book.
Or the wife was saying to the
husband, you know, this is a
really great book.
So all these guys
were reading it.
And then--
I'm not sure if this is
adjacent or not--
but then she discovered that
she had a gay audience.
So she was--
and she only discovered that
because she did all this
direct engagement.
She would go out to book
shows and do talks.
And all these gay
guys were there.
So she developed this
gay audience.
So she built these separate
audiences into
a very large audience.
Then there's a third one that
I call the secret audience.
And this is my favorite one
because everybody I've worked
with, including myself,
usually has somebody--
usually it's often
the individual--
that they are speaking to.
They may not even know who it
is, but it's often an issue of
revenge, of unfulfilled
promise.
So I'm writing to my third grade
teacher who said I'd
never amount to anything.
Or, my father who-- it's often
to my father who died when I
was 10 and I couldn't
show him whatever.
So there's a secret audience.
And you may not know who
it is, but you may
eventually get to it.
And the reason this is important
is it really helps
you focus what you're
trying to do.
Because you often think you have
an audience, and it feels
right, but then you really
discover you're trying to say
something a little different,
and you're talking to
different people.
So usually that secret audience
person represents the
audience you really
want to get to.
So, for example, one of my
secret audience members is my
brother-in-law.
And we have a perfectly fine
relation and everything.
But I wrote a book several years
ago and after he'd read
it-- which I appreciated--
he said, I don't know why
you wrote that book.
I don't know why you
wrote that book.
Why did you waste three years
of your life on that book?
And he kind of had a point
because my audience was not
clear on that book.
So I always have him in
mind when I write.
I say, is he going to say,
why did you write
that book, or not?
I'm really pleased to say when
he read this book he said, I
really enjoyed that book,
it was really good.
I said, oh my god, Glen,
I spent 10 years
thinking about you.
You didn't know that.
So then we get to--
we need another one?
Oh, we got two, we got two.
There are two.
OK.
There are two there.
Yeah.
So, now comes the question, so
how do you measure this?
You know, everybody
said , well, how
do you measure influence?
Is it possible to do?
Because it's not about finance,
it's not about money.
How do you measure
the influence
you're having on people?
How many people, et cetera?
So you can't directly measure
influence, of course, because
it's not financial.
But there are a number of
things you can measure.
So you can measure all
the expressions.
So you can look at your books,
your talks, and there are an
amazing number of things
you can measure.
Book sales are just the
most obvious thing.
But, you know, how many
talks am I invited to?
For academics, in particular,
how often are my ideas
referenced in other works?
That's a huge one.
Daniel Kahneman says his first
article about "Thinking, Fast
and Slow" is the
most referenced
article of all time.
I don't-- that's what he says.
But anyway, it is referenced
a lot.
So are you referenced lot?
Are you invited to lots
and lots of talks?
How many people show up?
How many Twitter followers
do you have?
There's just, I mean, there's
just endless metrics that you
can look at.
These are useful, however, I
have also had clients who have
great metrics that way and
have no influence.
So there's no direct correlation
between any of
those analytics and the
influence that you have.
So it's all a little bit
mysterious and upsetting.
I can tell you when clients come
to us, that answer does
not make them very happy.
They want to believe that
it's about sales.
And, in fact, I had a chat
with my doctor recently.
We were just chatting and he
said, so how's the book going?
How many books have you sold?
I said, well, actually,
I don't know.
I haven't checked.
He was like, you what?
You haven't checked
your sales?
I said, well, no.
That's really not the point.
He said, well, how else do you
know anything about anything
if you don't check the
sales of your book?
I said, doc, let's just get
on with the exam, OK?
However, you can usually come
up with some kind of metric
that may or may not be measuring
exactly what you do,
but that helps people gauge
what you're doing.
So Cesar Millan, for example,
uses euthanization of dogs.
He says every year 3 to 4
million dogs are euthanized in
the United States.
And largely that's because
people do not know how to
behave with their dogs.
He says that 6 to 10--
6 out of 10 dogs that are taken
home from shelters are
returned to the shelters.
There's some--
I don't know if that metric
is exactly right, but
that's what he says.
So those are two metrics
that you can use.
And you could say, well,
euthanizations are coming
down, or fewer dogs are being
returned to their shelters.
Now you can't directly say, I
caused that to happen, but he
can look at those numbers.
So you need some kind of
metric you can look at.
But, interestingly enough, the
most affecting and most
rewarding, and probably most
important one, is this one to
one, people saying to
you, you know what?
I saw you talk, I read your
book, it was really
meaningful to me.
It changed the way I think.
It changed the way I behave.
I do things differently now.
I tell other people about it.
And all the idea entrepreneurs
we spoke with said that is the
one that they found the most
meaningful and the most really
telling, because you know that
if you've directly affected
somebody, they're going to be
talking to other people in a
way that's not just, oh,
I read this cool book.
It's like this really meant
something to me.
So Tim Ferriss has this sort of
gang of followers, right,
who really, really
believe him.
So that one to one thing
leads to a one to many.
Finally, you start to think
about, so what is my very,
very long lasting effect beyond
the book, or beyond the
two or three years
when I go public?
And we get to what I call
the thinking journey.
And this is where you connect
the idea that you want to go
public with to other ideas, and
think about how does it
fit in a much bigger way.
So, you want to think about
how do you take the idea
beyond yourself when you're no
longer active, or you're on to
something else?
And there are ways to
think about that.
One is, are you linking
to some kind of
fundamental human concern?
And this is something that a
lot of people who want to
write books, in particular,
are not doing.
They're focused on a very narrow
or technical area.
But if you can link to a very
deep, fundamental human
concern, you got a pretty
good chance of gaining
some lasting influence.
So, to use Cesar Millan again
for an example, you know he
talks about dog training.
People think of him-- oh,
he's a dog trainer.
But he strongly believes that
he's about dog-human
relationships.
And that he is actually about
the state of American society
and our relationship
with nature.
So he's linking into a much,
much deeper idea.
If you take anyone of these idea
entrepreneurs, they're
always finding some fundamental
idea that they are
talking about.
They don't always say it.
They don't say it directly,
but it comes out.
Many people have this
idea of ownership.
I want to own that idea.
Consultants in particular
want to do this.
I want to be the owner
of that idea.
And I found that this is a
really good way to not own an
idea, is to say, I
own this idea.
No one else owns this idea.
I thought it up, nobody
else did.
So, the good idea entrepreneurs
say, you know, I
didn't think it up.
I am expressing it for
lots of other people.
I, of course, I added my own
thing to it and expressed it
in different ways, but
I don't own this.
I don't want to own it.
I want other people to own it.
I want other people
to add to it.
So don't try to own the idea.
And you've got to recognize the
relationship of your idea
to other ideas out there.
And no idea is wholly
original, or even
particularly original.
But they're originally stated
and they come out at certain
times that are important.
So link to those.
And then finally, if you can,
you want to trace to a very,
very long thinking journey.
So you want to trace back, and
you want to trace forward.
So when I asked Cesar Millan,
for example, I interviewed him
and I said, is there
anybody that you--
whose footsteps you would
like to follow?
Or you think of as somebody
who is kind
of a mentor, a leader?
He said, oh yeah, Gandhi.
I said, Gandhi.
Really?
He said, well--
I said, why?
He says, well, Ghandi has this
quote which is, the quality of
a society is judged by the way
it treats its animals.
I thought, oh, this is
pretty interesting.
So if you take Cesar Millan, if
you take Gandhi, his whole
thing was what he called
satyagraha, which is truth
firmness, which is sort
of civil disobedience.
And Cesar's method of working
with dogs is calm
assertiveness, which is sort
of the same thing for dogs
that Gandhi had for humans.
And you can trace this
thinking journey
really back to Buddha.
You can say Buddha, Gandhi,
Tolstoy, Martin Luther King,
Cesar Millan.
Perfect.
Perfect line.
All right, so, I want
to leave you with--
well I guess I can, I forgot to
take you through metrics.
So if you're thinking about
going public with an idea--
and maybe just within your
organization, or whatever--
these are questions we ask
our clients to answer.
And they're really obvious
questions that when I start to
show them to people they
start laughing.
Like, ha, absurd questions.
But they're very, very
difficult to answer.
And you can--
I'm sure you've heard people
flounder with these questions
trying to answer them in
many, many situations.
So for the idea entrepreneur,
I can give you the correct
answer for each one of these.
So the first one is, why
am I doing this?
And I cannot tell you the number
of times I've seen
people who say that, I want to
public with an idea, but they
can't say why.
What is driving them?
What is their purpose
in doing this?
And usually that means that
their purpose is that they
would like to become famous
in the ideaplex.
They would love to have great
blog analytics, and have
people say, wow, I read
your cool book.
That's really great.
It was on the front shelf at
Barnes Noble, or whatever.
That is the wrong answer.
And the right answer is you want
to do something for other
people, and that is what's
driving you.
I'm not saying that these idea
entrepreneurs are totally
selfless, that they don't have
healthy egos, but they really
want to do something that
changes the world for the
better as they see it.
I found this for myself.
We start working on a book and
you're so focused on, I got to
get this book done.
Can I get it done?
What am I trying to say?
But at some point
there's a flip.
And you say, oh, I'm actually
trying to help people out with
this thing.
Number two, what do
I want to achieve?
This goes back to the metric.
So very often you kind of throw
something out there and
say here's my idea.
I'm doing it because
of whatever.
But there's no specific
achievement that you're after.
And whether or not that's the
one you actually achieve, or
that's the one you keep focusing
on, you want to keep
saying, what specifically do
I want to have happen?
And that usually goes to
the practices also.
So do I want to see people
referring to me?
Do I want to see people
referring to my ideas?
Do I want to see them put
them into practice?
This third one, what is my
personal connection?
This is really tough.
And most of our clients really
struggle with this.
They don't-- you know, we're
taught in organizations not to
get personal, to keep it all
in the argument, keep it on
the data, but you have to
bring in these personal
connections.
Very tough to do.
Who am I talking to?
We talked about the audiences,
but very often somebody will
go out with an idea and they
will talk to the people who do
not need to be convinced,
people
who are already convinced.
So you've got to find a way
to that direct audience.
And the final one is what is my
idea in a single sentence?
And this is really hard to do.
I try to do it myself
every day and
sometimes I can't do it.
But you keep trying to refine
it because the world will do
that for you.
They will say, oh, he's the
guy who talks about the
ideaplex thing.
And that's all you're
going to get.
All right.
That's all you're
going to get.
So if your idea-- if your
sentence isn't really good and
if you haven't shaped if for
yourself, they're going to do
it for you and you're not
going to be happy
with it half the time.
So keep working on that.
AUDIENCE: Because that's
a form of expression.
JOHN BUTMAN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: That's a form
of expression.
JOHN BUTMAN: Oh yeah, I've
missed that one.
We talked about that.
Think about that, your best
form of expression.
So if after looking at these
questions and thinking about
your idea and who you're trying
to reach, if you decide
not to go public with
your idea, I applaud
you for that decision.
It's a really, really
good decision.
And more people should decide,
I don't think I'm ready, or I
don't think the idea is strong
enough, or I don't think I
could get to the audience.
Or I don't want to really
deal with the ideaplex.
I think part of the reason we
have this glut is everybody
thinks, oh, I'll just take
it out, and I'll
take my idea out.
I'll change the world, it will
be great, and don't do all
this stuff.
And so we have to sort of weed
through all this stuff.
So please, if you say no to
yourself, that's really good.
But if you think about these
questions, you think, well,
maybe I will.
The sort of the one question you
can ask that is absolutely
definitive is, can I not not
go public with this idea?
If you are so driven that you
don't care about everything I
said, you say, I cannot
not help myself.
I cannot not go public.
Then I say to you, godspeed
and good luck.
Now thank you very much.
So we got a few minutes
for questions, or
thoughts, or comments.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm fascinated
with the backlash.
And I would like to hear you
expound a little bit more on--
just say what you want to say
about [INAUDIBLE] your
observations.
JOHN BUTMAN: Well, especially
with social media, it's so
easy for people to
backlash at you.
It's a fundamental part of it.
I think it's actually a healthy
part of it, because if
you don't hear people's
objections to your ideas,
either they're being polite
or your idea isn't really
different enough and it's
probably not worth
considering.
So you really actually want
backlash and you want
intelligent backlash.
You want considerate backlash
where you can actually engage
in discussion with people.
And then you need to decide, so
what's the cut off point?
We've had people make comments
on our blogs, or on Twitter,
and you just say, well, sort
of look into the person and
say, this is not coming from
anywhere that's useful and
just kind of ignore it.
But it's very hard to do because
idea entrepreneurs
think, I am good.
I'm trying to change the world
for the better and these
people are thinking I'm bad.
And it's hurtful.
So you just have to accept that
and say it's actually a
good, healthy part
of the process.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You referenced
some clients.
I'm curious as to what sorts
of clients you had?
Businesses?
Or individuals?
JOHN BUTMAN: Yeah,
so, I don't--
I think I can't tell
you exactly,
specifically who they are.
But I can tell you sort of
generically who they are.
So working, for example, with
the president of a large
philanthropic organization.
And she has--
they have one basic theme
that they want to
get out to the world.
And say this is where we're
putting all of our money and
all of our effort.
So she's doing a whole campaign,
she's doing a book,
she's doing a bunch of
other activities.
So, she authors the book, we're
helping her think about
the ideas and create the book.
We're working with a serial
entrepreneur was is also a
lecturer at the Media Lab.
He's talking about the
future of technology.
So he wants to become sort of
the guru of the next wave of
technology.
We are working with a
guy who has been in
investment for a long time.
And he believes that
the history of--
the whole story of investment
has never been told.
And the reason that we are in
such a mess financially is
that people don't understand
what they did with their money
at all, and all they do is get
tips from people who have self
interest at heart.
So he wants to write this book
and get it out there.
So these people have the
means to support this.
And they're going out-- these
are the ones sort of at the--
well, not the entrepreneur, but
the other two are sort of
at the end of their careers.
We worked with a number
of consultants.
We're working with a French
consultant right now.
And his whole-- he's an
organizational guy.
So he believes that
organizations are dealing with
complexity in all
the wrong ways.
That instead of dealing with
complexity through human
intelligence, we're trying to
make our organizations so
rule-bound and complicated to
try to cover every possible
contingency, which
is impossible.
So those are some of the kinds
of people we're dealing with.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: To just go back a
little bit to the to backlash.
There's--
do you have ideas that generate
a lot of backlash,
they get a lot of air
time, because
everyone loves the debate.
Do you find that in the long
run, that ideas that are the
stickiest, that sort of permeate
and change the
thinking of everyone, do those
tend to be, or generate less
backlash up front or more
backlash up front?
Do you have a sense of that?
JOHN BUTMAN: That's a really
good question.
I haven't really thought
that one through.
But my feeling is that people
respond much better over the
long run to people who are
really genuine, are not
deliberately trying to create
controversy, and really want
to help you.
And the ideas may be difficult,
but they're not
deliberately controversial.
So my hunch is--
I think this is probably
your hunch--
is that those ones that really
spike and get a lot of
attention tend to disappear.
And the ones that really, really
last are the ones that
are deeper and stronger, and
they generate conversation,
but not so much backlash.
It's interesting, if you look
at on the Harvard blog site,
there's a real difference
between blogs that get a lot
of comments and the ones that
get a lot of readership.
So very often the ones that get
a ton of comments, they
don't last very long.
So it's just like sticking your
finger in people's eye,
and they want to
talk about it.
It doesn't mean that
it's lasting.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Back to the
respiration, a lot of what you
talked about had to do around
credibility, like when you
mentioned that Cesar Millan
really establishes tangible
credibility, immediately
and another example.
And in both cases, they are--
that their credibility, they
are pretty immediately
recognized, and so that's part
of the influence, that there's
immediate connection.
How do you factor in some of
these ideas take time for the
recognition of impact and
how does that become
a variable in influence?
JOHN BUTMAN: So, how long
does it take to--
AUDIENCE: Does that matter?
JOHN BUTMAN: It does matter.
I think there's usually a very
long accumulation period.
And people are, they're doing
all this, they're doing
respiration, they're doing
expression, but it hasn't
become really well known yet.
So Cesar Millan did a lot
of stuff, but then
he got this TV show.
He was actually approached to
do a TV show and that's, he
just, spiked him.
But, Mireille Guiliano spent
four decades gathering stuff.
People kept saying to her, you
have to write this book, you
have to write this book.
She said I don't want
to write this book.
My mother told me you should
never write books because
that's too self-aggrandizing.
And her friend finally said,
forget about your mother, it's
about helping other people
because I've seen you do it.
And she said, OK, now
I understand that
that's what it's for.
So when people come to us and
say, I want to be the thought
leader in this thing
by the end of 2014.
Sorry, no can guarantee that.
You have to have accumulated the
stuff, you have to go out
there and create respiration,
which you cannot be sure is
going to happen.
And it can take a long time.
Yeah.
Somebody else, yeah.
AUDIENCE: If we want to be good
at speaking, presenting,
and connecting with audiences,
what are
good ways to get practice?
JOHN BUTMAN: Ha.
That's a great question.
You know, take any invitation
you could think of.
And if you can't get any
invitations, then call
somebody you know and say, can I
come over to your company at
lunch and talk?
Almost--
AUDIENCE: Well, we have
a post-masters
group right in Google.
JOHN BUTMAN: Oh yeah?
I mean, you can speak--
there's always
somewhere to speak.
You know we, at the very
beginning-- we've done a whole
bunch of talks-- but at the very
beginning we just called
some of our friends and we
said, we've got this book
coming out, could we come
at lunch and just do
an hour long thing?
They said, yeah, why not?
So you can always just brow beat
people to let you talk.
And at the very worst.
You do what I call the
cocktail party test.
No matter where you are, with
anybody at anytime, as tedious
as it might be, you just start
telling them your idea.
And if-- you say my new idea
is blah, blah, blah.
And if their response is, oh,
that's really interesting
because I was thinking the same
thing, you know you're
onto something.
If their response
is, so, where'd
you spend your vacation?
Then you probably have
not hit it yet.
But you can always find
a place to talk.
That's a really good question.
Anybody else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: This is a question
about if you recall the
iconical form, like the--
JOHN BUTMAN: The iconic
moments, you mean?
AUDIENCE: Well, the sort of
idealized form of the idea
that you put out there.
AUDIENCE: Sacred expression.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry?
Sacred expression.
There are, I've seen a pattern,
a very few data
points, of books like "The
Long Tail," "Blue Ocean
Strategies," you know,
some of these sort of
big business books.
JOHN BUTMAN: Yeah, big
idea business books.
AUDIENCE: Big idea
business books.
That started with or mapped to
a article in "Wired" or in--
JOHN BUTMAN: "HBR."
AUDIENCE: "HBR," something
like that.
And, I've always found my path
through has been, someone
points me to the article, I read
the article, get really
excited about it.
Read the book, they're like,
why did that take 200 more
pages to say the same thing
as in the article?
Are those authors doing
the right thing by
writing their books?
Or are they, or should
they just--
JOHN BUTMAN: Well, I think there
are two answers to that.
One is, many of those
articles are written
after the book is written.
And they couldn't write
the article until
they write the book.
Because they had to go through
the process of writing the
book to get all those ideas.
Then it's so wonderful because
you can just squish them down
into an article.
That's why the article
is so good.
And so often you'll find that
the articles that are less
good do not come from a book.
If you-- a lot of the stuff
you read in the "The New
Yorker," for example, is
excerpted from books.
So you get the benefit
from all that extra
work in this article.
But, yeah.
I mean, very often you don't
need the rest of it.
But you do need the book.
And what we've come to the
conclusion is that all idea
entrepreneurs need a book.
It may not be their
sacred expression,
but they need a book.
And I can't tell you-- people
come to me and say, you know,
I'm talking.
I just did my TED Talk, I've
been blogging like crazy.
I've got to have the book.
Everybody wants the book.
And if you think about, the book
does a lot of things for
you that nothing else does.
So, I mean, people still think
of it as sort of the ultimate
emblem of learning.
I can write a book.
We've been told forever that
book is the ultimate
expression.
It's this very handy device you
can just hand to people.
It's an entry to the ideaplex
because that's how
you get into it.
You say, his new book,
as opposed to he just
posted a cat video.
That's not getting you
on Charlie Rose.
You got to have--
the book does a lot
of things for you.
But, you know, your criticism
is very well taken.
Many people feel the same way.
Do I need to read this
entire book?
And often, you don't.
AUDIENCE: Have you written
an article form of this?
JOHN BUTMAN: We did--
we have not written an article
in "HBR," but we've done
articles in various different
places, yeah.
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what is it the
metric that you are measuring
yourself against?
Is it tweets?
Followers?
JOHN BUTMAN: The number of--
the number, fewer clients that
come to knock on our door.
What is the metric?
That's a really good one.
The one on one metric really
means the most to me.
And that's one I'm paying
most attention to.
So that's kind of what
I'm focusing on now.
And we're still in the
early days here.
But if we could hear
people say--
if we could get this model out
there and get some sense that
people are kind of evaluating
ideas through this model, that
would be great.
Great.
Thank you very much.